how's it going bros my name is Jared
Jared not too loud she could hear us
Karen Karen Karen who is she
well she gives raisins to kids on
Halloween dude I like races drive some
se me to carpool her kids to soccer
practice better hope the referee doesn't
make a wrong call because she will so if
you have this haircut then your name is
Karen it's just written in the loss of
physics you can't deny it
stop pretending some people with this
haircut are now coming out saying no my
name isn't Karen listen you don't need
to write Karen on your hair the haircut
says it enough we know your name is
Karen stop questioning in it stop trying
to make us doubt it you're just
confusing after a long day of talking to
managers and driving her kids around she
sits down with her mom friends at the
book club and drinks lots and lots of
wine we talk about 50 shades of grey
Karen took the kids guys Karen took the
kids when you spend so much time making
Karen took the kids means that your wife
actually leaves and takes your kids just
like this why Karen why did you have to
take the case so this Karen Mimas going
on a long time on the Internet but what
makes it so funny is when people try and
silence a meme because that just makes
it ten times over more effective it's
just like the Burma means that was
around for a long time and it wasn't
until people said hey you shouldn't say
boomer because he hurts our pitch it's
now it's the same with Karen and it's
got their beautiful dear Millennials ok
I'm lit go ahead I'm listening
stop saying Karen even though I'm boomer
karen is a sexist thanks for
highlighting there's so much text there
that I it really it really helps that
you like lighting certain words Garrett
is a sexist and racist term equivalent
to the
[Laughter]
sorry for what someone wrote these
amazing absolutely incredible calling a
woman Karen is an attempt to get rid of
women super it gets better and better to
stand up for themselves
Oh Jared Darrin why did you write this
we're not gonna fall for your tricks you
just want the kids and you want to speak
to the manager what guess not guess what
I don't have a manager the only thing I
listen to is the floor Karen ultra Karen
seminar of district managers I did
something wrong
let me speak to the manager wake pack of
dogs Tareq's hey that's dark hair and
everyone should fear her you get eye
contact and you instantly get a
vasectomy so I don't that's that's not a
word found out that the study they
founded to prove vaccines cause autism
proved that vaccines don't cause autism
and then Karen freakin lost it that
haircut man Karen your name is Karen now
okay just accept the fact Karen oh yeah
Guardian posted as well the Karen meme
is everywhere and it has become my mired
I don't know how to say that word in
sexism yep that's what it's about you
did a guardian
there's my applause for a well done
research you did it
countless tick dog videos we can't count
down there's too many they're all
marinating sexism stop it stop it you
can't call it
you can't just cuz I had this haircut
doesn't mean my name is Karen haha Karen
hi Karen Julie the journalists think
that Karen is the same Julie's name is
Karen now hello Julie I don't mean hello
Karen how are you let's see what people
actually think alright so here we go
people voting that Karen does not have
any sexist or racist slur meaning to it
okay let's see here yes no that's a big
peepee right there I love democracy no
receipt no equals no returns no tanks
equals no returns clearance jewelry's
watches sale items equals no returns yes
Karen this site is good enough try me
damn someone dare to defy Karen no Karen
we do not have to mention the return
policy at the initial sale our return
policies printed on the back of the
receipt the details are also on the
website no Karen you are not going to
speak to the manager no Karen I'm not
going to call anyone that perfectly
encapsulated it the internet anyone
named Karen oh wait it's copyrighted
let me speak to your task manager damn
it
see they're trying to take over it's the
same with boomer now we have a word to
fight it back with Karen super Kara
damn captain Karen all right poor
people's home average people's home rich
people's home karen won the lawsuit she
took money I didn't know I had now she
lives in a freaking castle in Germany
with my kids well this is what happens
they just keep going recognized experts
over the time overtime that's right
Karen is knowledgeable in every field of
studies don't ever try to match her
intellect because she knows because she
read an article that she found on Google
okay that was posted on her Facebook
group of other Karen's leading
scientists PhD student media
but Karen on Facebook you can't fight
back it's too late Zoomers it's too late
karen has won Texas mayor broke her
owners say at home water to to go to a
nail salon okay Karen shut up Karen that
can I speak to a manager haircut there
it is wow I really can't believe how
people can be so judgmental over a
flippin airtight
yes my hair has been different lengths
of this style for years I've got nothing
but compliments on my hair but then
again everyone's entitled to their own
opinions dot dot dot but you don't have
to be such jerks about it
would you like to speak to the page
administrator about this shut up Karen
you're not taking the kids you're not
taking the kids Karen when they can't go
inside to talk to the manager during a
pandemic this is so sad
karen has lost all their power what
Karen does now is she takes photos of
people from the outside
she's got camera equipment that is
better than any paparazzi 5,000 zoom if
she catches you outside she's reporting
that that's Karen
you shouldn't go outside by the way I'd
like to talk to the manager I need to
speak to the regional director I demand
a parley with a chief executive officer
I require the presence of the board of
directors I rudely request a one-on-one
conversation with the company founder
it's imperative that I receive my way
with the President of the United States
I will leave up one star review unless I
have an argument with the UN I demand to
be made an equal without your Lord and
Savior I am Karen I am the lord I will
dictate and ultimate them where I cuss
out the Holy Trinity Karen Oh
Karen oh we might as well just give up
there's no way we can fight back at this
point let's get real hair gamers it's
not happening all right so let's look at
these countless tick-tocks I'm curious
with what this is all about best care
and tick-tocks
oh god she's terrifying
[Applause]
sorry but you're calling your windows
open they can't hear me cuz they're
listening the kids pop goddamn that's
the best response I've ever heard she's
always on top of everything don't ever
try to argue with me Karen that's the
first mistake you made right there Karen
your worker attacked me manager let's
check the security tape Karen Karen
never lies there has to be more evidence
of this I feel like this happens all the
time but now we have a word for it now
we can fight back it sucks simp
it's like boomer all this over again
what you're seeing now is my normal form
Oh God
god that's all Karen who ascended to the
ante VAX you've changed your hair so
what just wait
as she really found a way to surpass all
common sense
she must be bluffing I mean what would
that make her double entitled vital is
to go even further beyond this is
happening worldwide it's unreal but this
is the real how is she generating that
much ignorance do it mom
five Jeanne causes a very bad virus oh
my god just have any conspiracy theory
that might hurt hurt your kids and bam
you got a Karen on that shoe karen is on
all of it
here I thought conspiracies there's were
four people that with low self-worth
that want to feel like they know
something valuable but I was wrong it's
just Karen's there driving this entire
thing you know that meme with the
puppets Karen is on top all right Karen
meme gets a solid eight I really like it
it's me it makes me laugh and please I
really hope this spreads so that more
people will be against the Karen meme
because this is hilarious this is
hysterical this makes it so much fun
here next meme as you may have heard Kim
Jung hoon was on his death bed at least
there was rumors about it that he's gone
undergoing some sort of heart surgery
I'm I haven't really looked into it to
be honest I don't know exactly what the
updated I think the update is that he
was actually fine so all this discussion
came about who's okay well if Kim Jung
hoon dies who's gonna take over and it
would be his sister Kim yo young and oh
my god she looks absolutely terrifying
we thought it we had it bad I'm scared
for my life
she puppet meme again Kim your youngest
above Karen I knew it oh wait side note
now watch this video the other day and
it was kim jung-eun speaking dude he's
got the most badass his voice sounds
like he smokes like a hundred packs a
day or something I did not expect that I
expected it to sound like that a Turkish
guy that can't stop laughing
that's that's the voice I expected all
right back to back to Kim Yong Yong I
don't want to show this I really don't
but people can capture look look out
terrified she legs so people there Fine
Arts immediately started dropping in
left and right this is a red alert level
meme they really captured me perfectly I
swear to God for half a second I thought
this photo was real anime openings and
he may have stopped it oh god no ah you
did not need to do that you should not
have done that just because you can
doesn't mean you should stop it stop it
now please Oh oh my god Kim Yong Yong
gets well and sees all the memes we made
about him you know what is more
destructive than the nuclear bomb words
imagine how he feels right now huh bet
you feel bad about yourself for making
fun of the situation I would never do
that leaked footage of Kim jung-un heart
surgery alright let's watch
he'll be fine he'll be fine
those North Korea and doctors know what
they're doing you know if she takes over
it's game over Kim Jung Geun dice Kim
Jung those
oh what a missed opportunity North Korea
come on dude Kim jung-ho needs to have a
baby right now I named it those come on
come on that would be so epic Kim Jung a
heart surgeon after returning to South
Korea yeah it as the story turns out
he's fine look at that alright and
everything is back to normal thank God I
could not handle more of those Kim yo yo
I can't remember her name I can't handle
any more of those anime memes next me
finally you probably seen this it's been
everywhere on Twitter this freakin leg
mean and again I'm gonna take the moral
high ground
not because I'm a Karen because a this
is insensitive against people that don't
have legs okay don't make fun of it it's
not funny
did this work no it did it horses don't
have legs everyone know this cringe know
it did it no it didn't stop asking stop
okay I'm fine with this one this one is
okay yeah this one passes - actually
this one passes as well damn it I
laughed at this stupid name Oh Bravo
Bravo well done I take it back this meme
gets a pro is that the same that it's
the same person can't damn it alright
that was it for me in review hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please give it a rating five stars if
you want this March you can check it out
link in description thanks for watching
brofist in a world where science knows
no boundaries travel to land where no
tuber has been and
Laure never-before-seen landscapes
[Music]
beings that are extinct meet Mayan
actors ancestors who collect ancient
items rediscover your favorite
scientifically accurate dinos what will
you create
you